we said you can introduce a parameter a
separate other variable right which is
like a measurement Vasai or your other
measurement your X's and Y's that you're
used to and the classic example that I
gave you which you're already familiar
with is the unit circle okay the
parameter that we tend to work with for
the unit circle and really any circle is
that angle formed at the origin between
whatever Y goes to a point on the
circumference into the oceans a and B
positive x-axis so no big deal okay
that's the parameter and that will
define uniquely any point on the circle
given these parametric equations x
equals cos theta y cosine theta that is
the parametric representation of the
unit circle more or less anything right
that you think of as a function you can
replace the x and y with something
related to a parameter right so for
example you have a look through your
textbook you can take a linear function
or a circle or hyperbola this guy in
fact even though you I don't think it's
useful right the parameter for this is
really obvious like it's a very obvious
way to state it because we know that the
Cartesian equation of such a hyperbola
is it is why it was a little X so if for
instance you say let's put a point here
and we'll call the x value T and quality
because Y is equal to whatever the
reciprocal of the x value is right 1
over X then this I would just be saying
the reciprocal of this right 1 on T so x
equals T y equals 1 or T is a parametric
representation of that hyperbola and
obviously we can really bury these
however
you can get a different type but what
we're really focusing on the UM the the
main course really is the parabola okay
the most interesting things come out of
the parabola and yeah the most insights
okay
so here's my question right all the unit
circle the parameter what is the
parameter and the answer is it's an
angle okay and that's why we call it
theta and not just some random letter
because we tend to use theta behaviors
so if that is what the parameter is
referring to and like in my previous
example the parameters like temperature
or you know Jamie or whatever what is
the parameter for this parametric
representation of the problem this is I
should say this is the standard
parametric representation of the
parabola in exactly the same way that x
squared equals 4a y is the sort of it's
the it's the Morcant representation of
the parabola which goes through the
origin because he gives you a locus
feature namely the focal length right
there so what is tape what is tape I'm
going to help you see what T is okay but
put me on something which done we
haven't looked that for a little while
maybe calculus okay so have a look at
this guy we all just think about in
cartesian terms first because that's how
we met calculus before in
differentiation if i wanted to
differentiate this probably the easiest
way to get dy/dx is first to make y the
subject okay so let's do that I think
when the subject we have y equals I'm
just dividing through by this
coefficient you happy okay so from there
now that Y is the subject it's pretty
easy to work out dy/dx don't forget a is
a is the focal length it's just a number
okay so I don't need to worry about it
as a variable I just treated as a
constant do you want the edge okay let's
have it going so this x squared at the
top because there's a qu
on four eight and then I can just cancel
a tiny tiny bit
x2 hey now by itself that doesn't tell
you anything particularly groundbreaking
right but now let's think about the
parametric representation let's bring
this guy you okay so I'll put in a
little subheading so you can see that
I'm gonna do I'm gonna go in a different
direction right now considering the
parameter what additional insight does
thinking about it parametrically give us
right in this little away there what
what insight is thinking about feet up
give us on the unit circle and the mass
is very simple right the algebra is very
simple if i know that x equals to 18
then dy on DX will be X that's to 18 on
to a you see that so just simple
canceling gives me yes so what is the
parameter in this representation of the
parabola and the answer is the parameter
T is the gradient wherever you are
that's what the derivative tells me
right so for instance if I say it
alright to 80 80 squared - 8 e 18
squared okay if I say something like t
equals 1/2 and let's pick a value a say
a is 1 that's simple enough okay so this
is x squared equals 4 1 so that would be
this right in fact that if I remember
correctly this is question 1 in the
exercise we got okay so pretty T equals
1 for this parabola right when T equals
1 where am I in the same way that when I
say you know when theater equals 30
degrees where am I okay the XY
coordinates are just going to be 2 1
yeah am I just substituted correctly yes
I have so therefore what this says is at
two one the parameter the gradient is
one that makes sense he is x squared
equals 4y right
two words somewhere about there and sure
enough if I were to draw that tangent it
ought to have a gradient of 1 what if I
said how about T equals negative 1 I'm
gonna be on the opposite side right I'm
going to be wherever I need to be on the
parabola such that the gradient of the
tage it will be negative 1 that's what
the parameter is the parameter can be an
angle in this case it's a derivative
it's the great you now just as a quick
note this is all fine that's really the
result I wanted to show you but we can
take it one step further we didn't need
to think about this we need to go to
Cartesian terms in order to get this
result we could have gone straight from
the Cartesian sorry state for the
parametric equations watch what I want
is dy/dx all right you can't you get
dy/dx directly out of either of these
equations right because this X is really
a function of T right remember this when
we were doing sunscreen is a [ __ ]
temperature this guy Y is also from so
being that X is function of T and Y is a
function of T it makes sense to
differentiate them with respect to
whatever variable they're in terms of
namely T so we can work out each of
these independently DX on detail ok on
treating T as the variable to a is just
the constant hanging out the front so
what's the excellent beauty
it's just to that T is a t ^ 1 ^ do
sistema just assume I can do the same
process for dy MDT right
he's my variable so that pounds going to
come out the front and then reduced by 1
so I get to a team are you happy with
that now the reason I did though is this
because what I really want is dy all of
DX right I think back think back to
chain rule these three here for the
chain of derivatives right the dy the DX
that I want they're here in here and
what I need to get rid of what I'm
trying to do is eliminate out that DT
right in the similar way that the movie
and the promo so how am i right this I
want the dy on the top and I want the DX
on the bottom and I want my 50 T's to
cancel you see that so this is just
chain rule you see this before okay and
do you wanted it a already know what
that is that's 280 detailer DX be
careful I don't have DT of the X I have
its reciprocal DX on DT a big deal I'll
just flip it upside down and of course
we get the same result of that we
expected okay so you can think about it
really parametric terms you can go
directly from here to see the meaning of
the parameter okay so keep this in your
back pocket it's going to become very
significant but every time you get a
given a question and you're like okay
try t equals this try to equals that
what you're really fighting is the
gradient at whatever point you're
interested in that's what the parameter
is for this representation